from the New York Post new emails show
Dr Anthony fauci commissioned scientific
paper in February 2020 to disprove Wuhan
lab leak Theory
the the they show he prompted or
commissioned and had final approval on a
scientific paper written specifically in
February 2020 to disprove the theory the
virus leaked from a lab in Wuhan China
eight weeks later he stood at the White
House Press Conference alongside Trump
citing that paper as evidence that the
lab leak theory was implausible
so basically that is evidence of fauci
covering up malfeasance
gain of function research was being done
under his watch and he commissioned a
cover-up that is a definitive fact he
should be in prison
is Trump going to lock him up I don't
think he will is DeSantis no he won't so
who do we get to vote for who's going to
promise as part of their campaign to
arrest fauci at the very least Merrick
Garland should be completely removed
arresting him is a stretch the January 6
committee members who withheld
exculpatory evidence they should be
criminally charged as well you'd
probably want to not say you're going to
arrest fauci and when you get into
office just a rest of day one no no no
don't tell him you're coming campaign on
it and to be honest with you you should
talk about we should talk about that
kind of stuff all the time leading up to
the election because whoever actually is
the nominee nominee for the Republicans
that should be something that is
discussed openly and regularly and you
know I'd say I'd be on that debate stage
and I'd say that's a very fine question
you got there moderator I just want to
add Anthony fauci you better leave the
country now and go somewhere that
doesn't have an extradition tree with
the United States because day one you're
getting locked up it I would encourage
him not to flee because he's going to
get locked up
well they have to actually do it because
the whole lot
well the whole Locker up thing was like
a whole campaigning talking point and I
do feel like Trump was a bit soft about
certain things because he was afraid of
looking like a fascist yeah but like
we've seen now how the left play like he
can't he can't do that he's got to lock
him up for real I don't like running on
the the platform that you're going to
lock up your political opponents you
know if they say if it's illegal but if
the president does it it's not illegal
like the the guy had his oversight the
guy can make illegal things legal like
that's we kind of give that guy power to
do that he's the commander of the
military if he wants to commit a drone
strike he can do it he doesn't have more
power to make illegal things legal he
can kill an American citizen with a
drone strike apparently yeah well that's
illegal Obama Obama is a murderer legal
and illegal at the same time Barack
Obama murdered a 16 year old American
citizen that is not in dispute his name
was Abdul Rahman al-alaki and he was
executed on the under the orders of
Barack Obama in a drone strike on a
civilian restaurant in Yemen a country
we are not at war with so if it happened
if you run on a platform of imprisoning
every Mill military official and
politician that was involved in the
death of a civilian you're going to be
constantly sending everyone to jail
that's why I said bulletproof Plexiglas
box in the courtyard so everyone can
watch but then when you get out of
office they'll come for you and it's
like yes it's great it's a cyclical uh
destruction destructive maybe there
weren't so many cowards in government
who are like but I don't want to step on
anyone's toes because then they'll come
for me well the thing is they wouldn't
have these problems in the first place
Anthony fauci didn't just commission a
drone strike against one American
civilian he issued and lied and covered
up gain of function research on one of
the most panicked diseases ever to
strike the human race that he may have
been the progenitor of we know that
equal Health Alliance was involved in
the creation of this stuff and he was
funding or asking them to fund this
stuff for him here's what I would say
right now where we are we know that
fauci provided funding to equal Health
Alliance which provided resources and
funding to the Wuhan lab to do gain a
function back coronaviruses and it seems
two uh I could say two agencies
intelligence agencies the FBI and the
department of energy have come out and
said lab leak is the most plausible and
it would seem that if a virus is uh its
epicenter is right next to a virus
Factory probably was the virus Factory
where it came from now the question is
was the virus that was released the
virus that was paid for by fauci
I don't know it seems also likely but
the fact that fauci paid for the
cover-up in my opinion and tried to
cover up and lied about it he denied
being involved in the study that to me
reportedly that to me is Criminal to an
attempt to defraud the American people
and cover up political corruption and
malfeasance he should be locked up for
that and you know he was asked in my my
guesstimate is that someone was like hey
don't let anyone know Tony now's your
time whoever it was someone's like we
don't want to cause Panic we don't want
to blow the cover on Wuhan lab but that
still I mean at some point you know
what's his name the German pilot that
was the Nazi number three you know the
guy I'm talking about he hung they they
got he he met his aunt at the Nuremberg
trials he was like just one of the Nazis
but he was like one of the top Nazis
um Goring Hermann Goring is his name
so I I think prosecution is on Anthony
fauci's Horizon he's done us very dirty
and and the people around him did US
dirty and if you guys have have dibs on
him send it out blow it out blow the
whistle on this guy don't don't go down
with him
do it but like how they're trying to go
after Trump on
make-believe things just because they
wanted to
you know get Trump what what ever
happened with that with the I wanna I
wanna sorry just issue a correction I I
believe I had read before that he was
asked if he was involved with the paper
and he denied it but now I think all
it's saying is that he never admitted
the paper he was citing was commissioned
by him he commissioned it he signed off
on it and then he cited it as if it was
real right
that's right that's so dirty and a
position of authoritative power
administrative Force the highest paid
doctor in the country in 2019 or 2020
the highest paid
uh politic political uh administrator in
the country both doctor and a Ministry
of some of 440 000 like this guy has
been around for 40 years doing this and
he sold us out he in his behavior in his
desire to side with big Pharma put this
country on a death spiral I I don't know
what else to say he he has respond he
was
I I'm all about forgiveness but I will
forgive him in a prison cell like he can
go to prison and and think of war or
whatever I I don't know the punishment
that's not up to me he can be charged he
can be arrested for a suspicion of lying
to the public I don't know what the
crime exactly would be conspiracy
defrauding the American people from a
position of government but the thing is
like when you're in the government
Authority the CIA they're expected to do
that they're expected to undermine the
American people every curve and we let
and we like give them carte blanche to
do it that's part of that he's not he's
the director of the niaid or was but in
a global pandemic situation it's like
habeas corpus is off the table like
that's why okay then fine then in
cleaning up the mess habeas corpus is
off the table right
if Anthony fauci gets a freebie then so
do I when I arrest them that's the thing
if he gets a freebie then the next time
this happens there will be another guy
that gets a freebie we can't let this
keep happening right so that means when
elected president I get the same freebie
he got and that means I get to arrest
him
I thought you should go to jail and
there should be a closed captioned TV in
his uh in his cell that ran with Rand
Paul on the other end whenever he feels
like you're just mocking him just giving
him credit so realistically it should be
he should be investigated at this stage
yeah yes I don't know like I said I
don't know what the what the uh the
actual charger should be someone tweeted
at me that it should be dereliction of
Duty which maybe that's that's
reasonable again I don't know but there
should be an investigation
I mean even if he's just like fired and
loses his pension that should be without
question
um I don't know man we're so far beyond
watching these Terror attacks letting
these people just do these things the
January 6th thing to me is it's it's
it's it's bordering on seditious
undermining the constitutional rights of
the American people and I'm pretty sure
there is already a crime on the books
that if you use an office of government
to undermine the Constitution then you
are guilty of a of a felony I believe we
brought it up on the show before someone
linked it to us so if they are sitting
members of Congress the federal
government and they have denied this man
as due process rights by withholding
evidence I would argue they've broken
the law so uh you know Liz Cheney
Raskin the whole lot I have no problem
lock them up I have no problem with
throwing politicians in jail I have zero
problem with that but we gotta
investigate one step at a time because
if we just start screaming for ju for
like the punishment that's a big that's
not the direction we want to investigate
the situation if they are found
criminally liable then or at least it
looks like it then we'll indict them or
I suppose charge them and then
potentially indict them suppose the good
news for everybody is you can simply
show that video to your cult member
friends and family though they won't
believe it anyway it's real he was let
in he was led around he thanked the cops
for being so cool don't make some excuse
the talking circles about it yep
they'll say look I don't have the answer
because I'm not a cult leader but the
cult leader says shut up so you should
shut up
that's it with with uh
I got a guy's name again Jacob Jacob
chancelly I don't know I got optimism on
this one because I think if if someone's
gonna let go get let go it's this guy
they've already let go a few people when
the evidence becomes purported yeah one
guy got exonerated on every charge
because there's a video of the cop
Fanning him into the building and the
judge was like that cop told him to come
in he's not trespassing one guy tried
claiming it and there's a video of him
climbing like over a broken barrier and
he's like it says no TR your trespassing
it says not to do what you're doing
you're doing it you know what I mean
like nice try buddy
but for a lot of these people who are
walking around you know we talked to the
guy they call him Podium guy even though
what he picked up was a lectern they
lied about all of it
you know this guy was like he didn't
even know what's going on half these
people were just bumbling around wrecked
that old lady with the flag so I'm
trying to think the argument against uh
Jake uh chancelly would be if he's on
the steps of the building then he's
technically as he begun trespassing if
it was trespassing to be in the building
on the steps is that considered
trespassing outside stuff yeah on the
outside the issue is that on any given
day you can go to the buildings walk in
right but since it was a protest we're
going to do it this week would it be
considered trespass because if it was
already considered trespassing then
maybe the cops were like we're just
gonna keep this guy peaceful we're going
to keep him close by he's already been
locked him out of the building
peacefully it was one guy with nine cops
could have but like if someone's in the
process of committing a crime and the
cops see it they don't have to stop him
they can like watch and make sure things
don't get out of hand and then bust them
at the end if they want I think so maybe
they'll use that argument he was already
trespassing we were just there to watch
and figure out how to let him in they
were letting him into different room
after room show them how to get in come
on man there's like imagine it's like a
guy who's unarmed is in a bank and let
me show you where the vault is come with
me and then you bring up the Vault like
is Rob in the bank yeah like he's
waiting for after he robs the bank to
like put him under it'd be funny if
there was audio and it's chancelly like
walking up to the door and knocking and
the cops open he's like you got a
bathroom I can use like yeah come with
me and they walk him into the Senate
chamber and he's like hey and then they
arrested him right because if cop lets a
bank robber into the Vault they're an
accomplice unless they arrest him before
they leave I guess AOC said it that they
were cops who had let help some of these
people thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time